[Music]
if you were worried you wouldn't be able
to pay more money for extra content and
for honor then okay look I know there's
no way you were actually worried but
Ubisoft has announced as he's in paths
in addition to what will come to the
game as free DLC I'm Matt and you don't
have to pay anything for this GameSpot
news update for Honor's $40 paths comes
with six new heroes that will be
available to seasonpass owners seven
days before they're released to everyone
else it also includes elite outfits for
the DLC heroes and a day one war pack
which contains a Sunbeam effect for hero
modes three emblem outlines three gear
crates and 30-day champion status that
gives the player a number of XP and loot
boosts people who don't pay for the
season pass can still unlock the DLC
heroes by spending in-game currency and
on top of all that Ubisoft announced
that it will release maps modes and gear
for free after launch the publisher said
that season pass owners will get early
access to some elements of this
post-launch content for honor releases
on ps4 Xbox one and PC On February 14th
but you can play in an open beta on all
those platforms from February 9th to the
12th for more news on for honor and the
world video games stay tuned to game
spots